this morning we're focusing on major
crises that teenagers and children face
according to the cdc the proportion of
mental health related emergency
department visits rose more than 30
percent in kids 12 to 17 years old
during the first months of the pandemic
in 2020 and there was a more than 50
percent increase in emergency department
visits for suspected suicide attempts
among adolescent girls during one month
period in 2021 compared with 2019. jamie
howard is a senior clinical psychologist
from the child mind institute a
non-profit dedicated to children's
mental health good morning how you doing
good morning thanks for having me of
course of course so what are some
warning signs that parents can look out
for when it comes to depression in
children and teens
with depression what we want to look for
is some mood changes like depression
shows sadness and irritability
irritability more than sadness sometimes
with kids so that's something to keep in
mind changes in eating or sleeping and
loss of interest or motivation and doing
things that you used to enjoy doing
you know
i want to ask about irritability because
it seems like yeah teenagers are
always irritated with something
oftentimes parents because we don't know
what we're talking about what's the
difference between a teenager just being
a teenager and then as a parent thinking
you know i need to dig a little bit
deeper into what's going on right so
there's usually some functional
impairment which means when kids are
really irritable they're like pushing
friends away they're pushing family away
it's not just a momentary kind of thing
it's kind of sustained and frequent
let's talk about anxiety as well because
in addition to depression anxiety is
racking kids in this generation what are
some of the warning signs to look for
there
so with anxiety what we want to look for
is sudden onset of avoidance of things
that kids usually did sort of
comfortably right like going to school
suddenly they don't want to go to school
and it's unclear why and they might be
really sort of rigid about not wanting
to do that maybe that's something like
social anxiety they're suddenly afraid
of being embarrassed we also want to
look for changes in our in our physical
body so like increased heart rate
nauseousness sort of like complaints
about our physical wellness that's
another tricky one for adolescents right
because one day they wake up and they
may not feel good in that shirt anymore
or whatever so how do you know when it's
a crisis when it's just run-of-the-mill
adolescent bumps so again like with all
illnesses what we want to look for is
this functional impairment so kids need
to go to school so if the anxiety is
keeping them from going to school that's
a very important job that they have
that's when we want to say we have to
help you with this because you need to
function you need to be able to get out
the door and do your important things
what's your advice
jamie to parents who may can be
concerned about their kids
who they think could be contemplating
suicide or who appear to be very
depressed
what should parents do or say in that
situation so you want to ask very
directly are you thinking about hurting
yourself are you thinking about killing
yourself that always seems awkward
though because you think that are you
planting a seed or is it
it seems like an um
very volatile question to ask right but
all the experts we've talked to say you
have to be that direct you want to be
really direct and you want to say it in
a calm empathic way so it's not like an
accusation it's a it's an extension of a
conversation i've noticed you haven't
been feeling like so good lately you
haven't seemed like yourself and then
you open up a conversation have you been
thinking about killing yourself is that
part of it and then if the child says
yes but just sometimes it feels like it
would be easier not to be here that's
what we call suicidal ideation and you
want to get your child to a mental
health practitioner right away if they
say yes and i have a plan do you want to
ask that's the second question do you
have a plan have you thought about what
you would do then that becomes more of
an emergency and we want to contact
9-1-1 potentially if they have a plan
and a desire a strong intention to die
you can also call the national suicide
helpline 273 talk because they can help
you sort that out if you're having a
hard time as a parent are there certain
ages that you think are more vulnerable
or more
susceptible to this is it boys or girls
or is there an age it's girls and
teenagers are more likely to die by
suicide and the rates are going up
steadily over the past decade and a half
even before the pandemic why is that why
is that girls i mean
so there's there's a few different
hypotheses about it part of it is the
developing brain and the changes with
onset of puberty
and part of it is a sociological
explanation of some of the pressures of
being a young girl yeah um i'll take
this moment to have um
some transparency full transparency on
the show after you visiting us um i told
myself i'm gonna go home and i'm gonna
ask a very direct question which is
about suicide to my kids which we
communicate a lot but it's a question
that i've never asked so um i walked in
my house my heart was racing like never
before i mean i played in football games
we're on this show we have some very
high stakes moments um i've never had
more anxiety or nervousness um as a
parent so i walked up to my kids and i
went down the line and they all answered
very honestly and my daughter said
something that uh she never said to me
before she said you know
i've never thought about committing
suicide but i noticed when my brothers
are injured because of sports they get
more attention and i didn't know that
and
i bring this up because if we wouldn't
have had this conversation i wouldn't
have walked in and learned that small
detail about my daughter and having a
little bit more peace of mind knowing my
daughter doesn't have suicidal thoughts
um so for parents who might be nervous
about that first conversation because
for a lot of parents it is the first
conversation how do they hype themselves
up to do it so you don't have to
actually feel calm you just kind of want
to fake it as best you can that's good
advice yeah and you can rehearse it
ahead of time
the script take some some deep breaths
right like slow steady belly breathing
actually really helps to reduce our
anxiety and then you can have an opener
like you know i was watching the news
this morning and these people were
talking about this and i thought well i
haven't asked you and then you can use
that as the opener
hey that's great yeah thank you so much
jamie we appreciate it advice that is
very good information all right if you
or someone you know is seeking mental
health resources you can call the
national alliance on mental illness
helpline at 1-800-950-620
in a crisis you can text nami to 741-741